foreign
[Music]
I do have to say it was really
incredible watching you last season as I
say the journey that is Roy Kent is
something that we love so much but I
have to say the rom-com episode will
forever live in my heart like just all
of the references everything that you
did for that I know you're like a huge
rom-com fan so I just have to say like I
know it's Harry Met Sally but yeah how
much of this rom-com like Renaissance
are you into and when do we get you in
one that's the bigger question
Jacqueline I like these questions
I would love to do a rom-com you you
you're on to me
uh yeah maybe I'm working it maybe I'm
writing some stuff we'll see we'll see
I'd love to no I really do dig that and
this definitely give us something to
like keep an eye out for but the other
thing I loved too I know we're getting
ready for what you guys are saying is
maybe the end of the story that we
wanted to tell but so much of last
season the thing that we loved so much
was watching you with your niece I think
of everything that we've sort of seen
with Roy Kent thus far that relationship
with Phoebe is just the best but you're
not really shy with the curse words is
that like do they do extra fines is it
like is it something like the child
minders are worried about it or you just
know that when you get casts alongside
them you just gotta deal with them I
think it's in in any contract with any
kid actor in it it's like if you have a
scene with Brett that's gonna be
swearing and you're right Rumble with
that or you're not but I agree with you
in the I love the scenes with Fabian I I
think their relationship is really
it's very I mean it really is special
she's amazing Melody is amazing she's
the best actor we have in the show she's
also the smartest you know that the
Story of Roy and Phoebe is it's really
beautiful because you go because you
know I know that Roy is this kind of
stoic that kind of assumes the worst of
everything and I think his sister had
this baby and the the father left and
Roy moved to Richmond so that he could
help raise her but I don't know that he
he probably wouldn't have been like oh
great news he'd have just done it
because he had to but he loves this girl
you know he loves it and she loves him
and they have this very special it's a
really beautiful thing I really love
those scenes I'm glad you like them
is there any like little girl like that
in your life
you're like
just like that I do have a Nace and I do
swear
I do swear all the time and uh
she's she's uh she's lovely what a
lovely girl I dig it um we actually
talked to Brendan we talked to Coach
beard and he mentioned how not only did
you write beard after hours but you kept
it away from him for so long like now
we're hiding it from him desperately and
he talked about how frustrating that was
it was the only script he ever didn't
get to know how much fun was it adding
those little touches to this character
who we obviously see almost every time
we see Ted on screen but he's so
soft-spoken he's a man of few words but
you know that he's just as integral so
what was it like giving him extra color
I mean that was really fun it was fun
for a number of reasons one because we
got to make a show like it was almost
like what would Ted lasso be if it was
from Beard's point of view so it's
completely different the theme tune's
different it's a different vibe it's
much darker so dark it's much kind of
trippier uh but also I love seeing
Brendan Hulu but I love seeing Brandon
dance so he's like how can we that was
like the end point we knew it's ending
in Hulu been and dancing you know Jason
always says like a love letter to
Brendan it's like we're giving him these
gifts because we know he's gonna nail
all of this stuff that he doesn't
normally get to do and the other thing I
love about beard after dark is that
there's the suggestion that the night
you see him have is pretty much like
most of his nights this isn't a one-off
crazy night he had it's like whenever
he's not with Ted this is the kindness
that is happening every night I took
that I really do I love that if you
could tell me which one of your co-stars
had the best reaction to your MCU cameo
shout out their name real quick I would
love to
Hannah
I could see that I could really see that
[Music]
first of all it's good to hear your
voice as one of my favorite non-verbal
actors on this show you give us a lot of
face I will say that it's actually uh
quite enjoyable to watch but I will say
coming back for this season that's I
think a big part of your character is
alongside Ted he is sort of that like
again that just that non-verbal beat and
so much of what you do on screen is that
is that something that you relish as a
writer and like somebody that crafts the
show that you're sort of like putting
little touches in there for yourself
I don't know like it's when we're when
we're writing the show you know there's
so many of us in the writers room who
play characters in the show I I think we
do a good job of compartmentalizing you
know and just serving the story as
opposed to uh getting too much into like
you know what I'd like to do uh climb a
tree and but that just opens it up for
like everyone in the room gets to gets
to throw in stuff they'd like to to see
me do or Brett do or or Jason or Phoebe
do so yeah it's still it's still a group
effort um but I always take
great joy in uh in discovering what
they've thrown my way well that brings
my next question this past season we got
beard after hours we really got to to
spend some time with Coach beard in a
way that we hadn't how did the sort of
story that they ended up going with what
what did you know how much did you know
going into it what was the most
surprising thing when you opened up that
script
um yeah I mean when we were working in
the room a little bit I knew you know
some of the major elements but then
um it was taken away from me in a way
that no other script has been
um it was basically was basically
stripped of producer duties on that um
episode until finally it was like a week
from shooting I was like hey guys I need
to I need to read the script and they're
like fine fine the biggest surprise was
uh the whole world of uh bones and honey
um I thought bones and honey was a
really hilarious name for a shishi you
know Soho House rival and our uh our
production uh designer had fun with
bones and honey as well once we finally
got there you know if you look closely
at bones and honey there's like a lot of
little
fun things going on there
um and uh minor spoiler we returned to
uh to certain rooms and bones and honey
this season so uh it has borne long
lasting fruit oh there's
I dig this okay so you did say it's the
end of the story you wanted to tell what
does that really mean
um and and if so what are some places
that you would want to explore in these
spin-offs
um I didn't say anything about spinos I
mean golly well he did he said that you
guys might be able to do spin-offs since
it's like the story you wanted to tell
in my like detective story I said that
that meant that it's automatically
spin-offs
well then you should interview you and
you see what you think the spin-offs are
um no I mean you know we're we're still
Landing this plane before we can think
about uh you know what other what other
uh you know Spitfires and and migs we're
gonna get up into the air we just gotta
we gotta get through this
um and and yeah and maybe maybe it'll be
spin-offs but maybe it'll be still some
version of the Atlanta like everything's
on the table right now
um but but we just cannot see that far
ahead
um until you know until we get this
thing out in front of the world and and
see what they have to say about it okay
I could just hear the Apple snipers
right now being like you you did so good
I tried to trick you you did not fall
for it at all
not my first trick Rodeo I'm afraid
thanks coach
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
this is like Return of the Jedi this is
after the shocking betrayal and like
we've seen so many like in so many shows
when you see somebody sort of like break
bad obviously Breaking Bad is one of
them what was it like for you to sort of
really lean into your Anakin Skywalker
turn this season I like these Star Wars
analogies um I I loved it you know it's
a challenge at times if I'm honest you
know a lot a lot of my previous acting
roles have been you know committed or
like pretty much exclusively comedic and
um you know season one night is a
comedic role um it's only really I think
in season two where we start to see the
sort of darker side to May and um his
sort of steady decline
um where actually a lot of the the humor
became you know there was still humor in
there for that role but but you know
there was also a lot of emotion and
dramatic stuff in there uh that you know
I'm just less
certainly have less experience there and
um so I feel you know I took a lot of
coaching sort of getting through that
but yeah a joy because you know it you
know who would have ever guessed that a
supporting role and one like Nate would
be able to kind of go on such a drastic
journey and it's you know a testament to
the writers for being able to to do that
so realistically I think yeah don't sell
yourself short the Emmy voters are
watching Sir this is not what we're
going for here
yeah I completely deserved it
well no I mean I think if there's
something for you to look at for like
anything to be so proud of that scene
where you blow up at Ted I mean that to
me is just like that was everything that
that fight was everything and as much as
like nobody likes to watch that show and
want to see Ted get his punches let's be
real there were some punches that maybe
needed to be pulled what was it like for
you sort of approaching that day because
you kind of have to yell at your boss
and like do a good job at it
I was aware that that scene was coming
so there was quite a lot of not pressure
but I just knew you know I was like okay
come on this is going to be a crucial
scene in the season finale of season two
um and you know typically Jason in a
very sort of ted-like way would always
like are you comfortable with this and
actually look at this and you know he
really genuinely kind of coached me
through it and um you know we had Declan
Nanny brilliant director as well
um
um but I feel like
you know Jason's got this really great
way of really getting into your head in
a really good way in terms of evoking a
performance and finding a truth to it
such that you can really latch onto that
so it has an authenticity so you know by
the end you know especially when Nate
breaks a bit and starts to cry I mean
it's all just almost real because we
sort of wound each other up sort of so
much to sort of get to that point and it
didn't take long to film actually
um I remember like we didn't do many
takes of it like we kind of tried to
sort of get it done late morning and um
I think they very kindly shot my
coverage first because I was sort of
feeling like it I sort of could sort of
just go for it and um yeah they're just
a really great competent cast you know
crew who who very sensitive on set when
there's a particularly emotional scene
or anything like that so yeah I felt
very lucky to be supported so much in
that um and um
yeah but it was undoubtedly challenging
yeah I do have to ask did you enjoy the
suits was the upgrade in the wardrobe
good give me thumbs up thumbs down real
quick yeah no I did I think the black
suit's an Armani suit and that's really
nice but I didn't get to keep it foreign